(Water lapping gently)
The Lord is with me.
I will not be afraid.
What can a mere man do to me?
(Door slams)
The door is kicked in,
overseers storm inside,
seize Peter, who violently
resists.
Overseer:
I said now, boy.
Peter:
Do not touch me!
Scipion moves into help.
Scipion:
Papa!
Adam Stephenson:
Betsy cries.
Get back, boy!
(Fighting Noise)
Sheer chaos.
Peter:
Help!
This was without
question the hardest film
of my entire career.
I live in doubt from
the moment I say "yes"
to a character until a magic
moment.
Will Smith:
There's a magic moment of
comprehension,
Will Smith:
and you never know when
that magic moment is going to
show up.
Dresser:
They arrive at the Rebel camp
still barefoot.
-Barefoot, okay, that'll
be fine, that'll work.
-Okay.
That'll definitely work.
Dresser:
If you want to at
this point..
Man On Left:
He's tricked out.
Man:
I think it's gonna be easier
for
whoever's putting it on him.
How does that feel?
Man:
We're hoping that that
will always go over the...
Man:
You'll have this little box.
Yeah, yeah, come
underneath.
There you go, come underneath
first.
Man:
Get your head out of there if
it's starting to waggle out.
Yeah, that's nice.
Whoa.
Will Smith:
It turns off... your... agency.
You don't want to step,
you don't wanna move,
you don't wanna look anybody in
the face.
It's deeply dehumanizing.
It's like in the most basic,
simple textures of human
interaction,
you just, you turn it off.
You just turn it off, you know.
It's a, it's gonna be a long,
hard summer.
♪♪
Pierce Austin:
Hair is, I think, is
paramount and essential
Pierce Austin:
to the character I'm hoping to
create.
A man who is strong, a
man who has integrity,
Pierce Austin:
and a man who has had a very
rough life, to say the least.
Pierce Austin:
The shape has to be flattering,
but it has to tell a story
Pierce Austin:
that he's never seen any vanity
before.
Pierce Austin:
He doesn't know vanity.
Will Smith:
Pierce Austin, my hair
stylist,
did such a brilliant job.
It's like nobody notices
that that's a wig.
Will Smith:
It's a wig that disappears
in the mind of the audience,
but it's so critical in
delivering the character
and, you know, touching that
space inside of the audience.
How his hair looks is so
critical, yet it disappears.
♪♪
Will Smith:
Hair and makeup and wardrobe is
always one
Will Smith:
of the first thresholds for
me to fall into character.
Will Smith:
You know, once I see myself in
the mirror,
Will Smith:
it transforms your thoughts and
feelings.
Will Smith:
It changes how you walk.
It changes how to hold my mouth.
The makeup definitely
intensifies
whatever Peter is experiencing
that day,
Judy Murdock:
and I have to keep that in mind
every day.
Peter, coming into
the construction camp,
this the first time he arrives
to this slave encampment
where he's been abducted from
his family.
Director:
Alright let's clear the set,
please.
Director:
Let's stand by, picture will be
next.
♪♪
Will Smith:
That Confederate War camp
is one of the best designed
and most accurate sets I've ever
been on.
(Hammers clinking)
(Horse whinnies)
Will Smith:
All of the sound.
The life of the camp got
created.
Will Smith:
You can feel the pain.
You can feel the suffering.
Will Smith:
It's like the walls are talking
to you.
Will Smith:
It made it that much more
difficult to emotionally depict,
but as an actor, it was
spectacular to be surrounded
and immersed in that way.
So it's the same thing, with a
thin shield
on the outside with some color.
They should fit.
How do they feel?
Not bad.
And yeah, they always help
with dialect anyway, so...
Good to see you, how are you
doing?
Arron Speiser:
You want to hear the dialogue?
- Is that what's the difference
between that and the others?
- Yeah, there is dialogue.
Steady yourself, long day out
here.
Steady yourself, steady
yourself.
Will Smith:
Steady yourself, a long day out
here.
Will Smith:
A long day out here, a long day
out here.
Steady yourself, a long day out
here.
The dialect is a major
part of the storytelling.
This is just work.
Peter:
Same as you always done.
Will Smith:
Peter's dialect is Haitian
Creole.
Will Smith:
Just prior to the Haitian
Revolution,
the slave owners were escaping
and they were coming to America.
A huge Haitian contingent
came into that Louisiana area.
Will Smith:
So Haitian French was
the best guesstimate of
what Peter probably spoke.
I do not know why God shows
Himself
to some people and not to
others.
But if you do not know Him,
I will pray for you.
Will Smith:
Peter's spirituality was one
of the most interesting
explorations for me to understand
Will Smith:
how someone can survive
this level of brutality,
Will Smith:
this level of suffering.
And it came down to Peter's
faith.
Will Smith:
You learn all your lines,
you learn your dialect,
Will Smith:
you get your hair, you get your
makeup, you, you know
Will Smith:
you rehearse with some
of the other actors,
Will Smith:
you do all of those things,
but what could give a person the
fortitude
and the endurance to be able to
sustain
Will Smith:
with that level of
violence and malevolence,
and, you know, God was the only
answer.
Will Smith:
There's a magical moment when
you understand a character
Will Smith:
in a non-intellectual way.
There was an interesting
thing in Peter's writings
Will Smith:
where he had been beaten into a
coma
Will Smith:
and he had been unconscious for
months.
And when he comes out, he
talks about having met God.
He heard and cultivated
a relationship with God.
Will Smith:
He felt like he knew God.
So he had gone beyond faith into
a place
Will Smith:
that few of us get to visit.
I just, I love working to
understand the mindset of that,
Will Smith:
that kind of character.
It's not a movie about
slavery,...
♪♪
Will Smith:
...it's a movie about freedom...
♪♪
Will Smith:
... and the power of faith
combined with love... being
invincible.